to afghanistan now where taliban
fighters are making gains across the
country forcing many afghans to flee
most are headed west crossing over the
border to iran
many will continue on from there into
turkey where the media are reporting
increasing numbers of migrants arriving
every day with refugee facilities in
turkey already overcrowded
most afghans hope to continue on to
europe
observers worried that this latest exit
is from afghanistan is just a start
and could escalate in the coming months
well for more i'm joined now by mustafa
ben masood he's chief of field
operations in afghanistan for
unicef that's the un's emergency
children's fund
thank you for being with us mr massoud
give us an idea
of what the humanitarian situation is
like now in afghanistan is there
any place in the country that's really
safe
thank you for having me let me give you
maybe a little bit of perspective on the
situation right now
in afghanistan for 2021 we've planned
for
18 million afghan in need of
humanitarian assistance
that number is rising sharply
for 2021 we've planned for approximately
9.7 million children in need of
humanitarian assistance and that number
is rising right now
and unfortunately this year since
january 468 children
were killed and that number is also
rising
the situation is extremely
um worrying for for us
and the price that is being paid by the
afghan population
the woman and the children is on the
rise
every day now many of afghanistan's
youth
had gained access to education and
other opportunities with international
support do you think those opportunities
will still be there moving forward
the conflict has spread to the entire
country
and we know what is the drive for people
and children to leave their places and
to be
to add the numbers to the to those
refugees and
migrant and usually it's the conflict
it's extreme poverty
and it's violence in general afghanistan
is facing a triple crisis
the conflict has escalated the drought
has
was declared few weeks back and the
third wave of kovid
is adding to that but even before that
afghanistan was
facing extreme challenges and i can add
a fourth crisis which is
the polio and the immunization campaign
that have to
to stop so the population is pushed
outside their area people you know
talking about the
people fleeing um they people are
fleeing the taliban's advances uh
where are they going to go uh could
we be looking at another refugee crisis
driven by conflict and
drought for example as you mentioned
that is most likely something that will
we'll
we'll see and witness in the in the
weeks and months to come because as i
said the conflict has come to
the villages and the houses and women
and children
have no nowhere else to go in
afghanistan
if we don't put a stop to the violence
and they will have no other option but
to make their way to
pakistan iran and elsewhere and adding
uh to the number of refugees and you
know that
60 of the refugees are
[Music]
young young people below the age of uh
of 30. mr masoud thank you very much for
taking time to talk with us today that
was mustafa ben massoud unicef's chief
of field operations in afghanistan
you